red how are you this morning or how are
you and my awesome and Danette we've
been watching a lot of basketball I've
been flipping around and I don't know if
I'm watching great basketball but I am
it's interesting basketball right now so
what what is the headline so far from
the first couple of weeks of the season
number one injuries Jeremy Lin obviously
last week I called twice and about the
Gordon Hayward injury Chris Paul
out two to four weeks because of the
knee injury I think trying to get to the
finish line it's probably going to be
first and foremost I know we're only a
week and change into the season but
we've had significant injuries I don't
know if it's because we had less
training camp time because the season
was moved up to kind of shorten the
back-to-backs maybe guys aren't and as
great a shape as they normally would be
but injuries first and foremost probably
come to mind and Yanis auntie to Khun PO
I know people say you can't win an MVP
in the first month but you could sure
make a case about it and auntie to Khun
PO has gotten the Bucks off to a great
start as well as himself for an early
season MVP candidate can he shoot reg
because I watched last night I didn't
see him shoot a jumper and he still
ended up with 32 points
he's an opportunistic 3-point shooter
and again this is easier said than done
but he can get anywhere he wants on the
floor because of his length you know at
seven feet and you know those long
strides in dribbling the basketball one
two dribbles he's already at the rim so
my question is does he really have to
shoot and if you're defending the buck
and Yanis you've got to obviously make
him shoot that jump shot yeah but when
you can't stop them and he's one dribble
and he's at the rim it's very difficult
to do that explain to me the Dwyane Wade
situation with Cleveland where he's
taking himself out of the starting line
and he says all be on this second team
coming in I I think a smart move by
train I thought all along him coming to
the Cavaliers personally him plane on
the second unit is going to help the cab
I know throughout his career Hall of
Fame career first valid arguably a top
probably the top three or four shooting
guard ever but at this point in his
career coming off the bench serves the
Cavs better because number one he'll get
more shots they'll get more touches run
that second unit and if people are
thinking that we're gonna see the Dwyane
Wade that we saw in Miami for so many
years you know the that time is somewhat
passed them he's still good but on that
second unit you know running with
Tristan Thompson Kyle Korver I think
it's a much better fit for Dwayne he's
not going to be able to get those same
shots in that starting you know with
Kevin Love and LeBron James I think the
game is a little bit too fast for him
not to say he's not gonna play down the
stretch I think he will but I just think
him coming off the bench eventually this
was going to happen regardless I thought
I was surprised that he was a starting
opening night maybe because it was
opening night but I just think it's a
better fit for him to come off the bench
for the Cavs
by the way reg will be calling Celtics
in the Bucs coming up Thursday night at
8:00 Eastern on TNT the Phoenix
situation is interesting that how does
how does the row Watson get fired three
games in Eric Bledsoe
doesn't want to be there and how did
they get to this situation this point
well number one it's unfortunate because
the coach is always usually the first to
go and a lot of times he's got to start
pointing fingers at the players because
the players got to play the games and it
was what the worst opening night lost in
NBA history versus Portland and remember
CJ McCollum
what's the spin to that game it didn't
even play for the Trailblazers and you
have the worst opening night loss ever
at home so the first the coach is always
the first to fall on the sword but look
what we were I'm not surprised at Eric
Bledsoe
because there was question first of all
the Phoenix sentence really didn't want
to give them that money a couple years
ago yeah and I think it went up to the
last hour with let's those men a lawyer
and agent as well as management of the
Phoenix Suns and they got a deal done
but I don't think he's really been fully
committed to the Phoenix Suns all along
so here we are and I'm sure there's a
number of suitors especially with you
know we talked about the injuries you
know we're hearing Clippers we're
hearing Denver we're hearing the Cavs
obviously he's close friends with LeBron
James they share the same agent enriched
Paul so we're hearing a lot of suitors
but it can't be an impulse you got to be
sure you get something for him if you're
gonna train him away
Lonzo ball we've seen good and we've
seen bad and now he's got John Wall
coming up there's already been some
back-and-forth with Twitter here how
long does it last where he has that
bullseye on his back I think it's gonna
be all year but when did all this
Twitter via what why does everything
have you played out over Twitter
Theodore I don't got to be a story on
Twitter now this is getting ridiculous
and look you and I talked about this
while he was at UCLA as much as his dad
shows that support he's put the biggest
bullseye on
Lonzo as well as his son and it's one
thing to be bravado and to say
outrageous things I get it but these
point guards and that's today's NBA is
driven by point guards you've got to be
successful you've got to have a great
point guard this league is driven by
elite point guards they're coming after
this dude and Patrick Beverley he stated
that and John Wall is one of those guys
who plays with the chip on his shoulder
so every night he's going to have the
bullseye he just has to go out and play
hopefully pops you know I hate saying
that because we give him a platform yep
but poshest needs to let his kid just
play he's going
mistakes and we've seen the good the bad
you know death calls it's called being a
rookie stall being a rookie gonna happen
if you can invest in Ben Simmons Alonso
ball given that both guys playing point
similar not great shooters although
Lanza was better than Ben but what would
you invest in if they were stocks do I
get to form the team after that no
that's your starting your team with
Lanza or Ben oh I'm probably going to go
with Ben Simmons because I had the size
to you know he can play one through four
in today's NBA and I mean Simmons is
kind of a harken back to that Magic
Johnson Penny Hardaway type point guard
where you have sighs at the point and
you can look over the defense yeah you
could play him a point forward as well
all uh Scottie Pippen Grant Hill he's a
walking triple-double the key is gonna
be health you know people say this is
his rookie year I he probably will end
up winning Rookie of the Year but I
don't like to say that because this is
his second year and he was around NBA
players in be a talent in be a trainer
so he's not really a rookie because he's
been in a system already a year but he
will probably end up winning Rookie of
the Year after missing last year because
of the injury why is it guys can't shoot
free-throws what have you seen mark
helpful yes number one pick prints that
is horrible how can that happen from a
number one pick and a guard I can see
big men because they have big hands and
they're just uncomfortable but there is
no excuse for Andre Roberson of Oklahoma
City for Markel faults for rajon rondo
there is no excuse for guards not to
shoot at least 70 plus percent from the
free-throw line
look dude was note I know folks is
bothered by a shoulder but I i watch him
play and I'm going I I'm waiting for
something I'm waiting for like marquel
folds to act like he would be the best
player in the draft or the number one
pick here and I haven't seen it yet why
is that I'm gonna go with I hope his
shoulder is the thing that caught
and him to shoot free-throws like that
I'm gonna give him the benefit of the
doubt in couture because if it's not if
it's not those are terrible mechanics he
has and he needs to go back to the
drawing board for the overall number one
pick to shoot free-throws like that that
is that's not a good look
it really isn't and I know they've been
trying to manipulate it and change it
while he's been in Philadelphia but that
is not a good look
yeah you watching you go I never saw
this in college and maybe at all right I
just I didn't see it and then all of a
sudden you go wait what happened to you
well remember he didn't play in summer
league he got hurt what first game yeah
so he really he's been under wraps I
mean what is the deal what's in the
water in Philadelphia I mean embiid is
not even he's not even cleared to play
back-to-back games
he looks good though when he plays
Reggie hey man good you know what I like
about Joe Alvin bead he is talking noise
to all this I mean I throw back he goes
on the lights I know he just played
Detroit and Tolan said Andre Drummond
doesn't play deep where's the
competition stop all the hugging and
let's go have dinner after the game this
dude this dude is talking noise that's
why I like him he doesn't back down and
he talks noise to the other centers did
you learn to hug anybody like how much
you hurt you you gap and you give that
fake bro hug right right before jump
ball but you know you you don't hold the
hug is less than half a second less than
half a second yeah I watch what the Cavs
did with a Kyrie and I'm thinking this
dude didn't want to play with you guys
and everybody's waiting in line like
it's a wedding reception to do their
special handshake I didn't like it at
all that's a little different
you didn't want to play with you he did
he didn't but for the fact he won he
helped win the championship with you and
went to three straight NBA Finals so
there's a little bit of
history there what I'm talking about is
guys that you maybe with the same agency
or just all a you guy teammates when you
were 12 years old hugging it out you're
25 now you can't I got it played I mean
but for the fact he had the biggest shot
in Cavs history now come on they should
be tapping him up did you when did you
make one magic and Isaiah kissed that
was in what 89 right they went to the
finals yeah 88 and 89 you know it's one
of those two years where this happened
right yeah I mean childhood friends
right I never would have kissed Michael
Jordan if you did that to Larry Bird no
I could I could see I could see you know
you could you would have you would have
messed with John Starks come here John
are you going to the Dodgers you going
the World Series at all you know where
my own I know that's right you're an
agent you're always going fat you're an
angel ah good luck to them I hope they
do well I really don't like the
Nationals and the Orioles is like the
Mets and the Yankees I grew up I was a
half hour away my brother played for the
Angels I'm a die-hard angel fan I know
the buzz around here is Dodgers Dodgers
it's just not me I'm loyal people that's
the problem I thought you might go oil
just to be seen though trying to get me
to sit in this box with them so out of
respect to my mentor I would go because
I love me some Magic Johnson but I just
can't go just to be seen that's the case
I'm gonna go hang out with the big
ballers himself loved arms
I can't see that happening either no
that would not happen reg will be
calling the Celtics and the box Thursday
night on TNT at 8:00 Eastern reg safe
travels great talk to you talk to you
next week
seat or you are truly the best damn it I
love y'all's thanks ran for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]